for someone to be identified as Muslim
they must believe in Allah and also they
must believe Muhammad is the prophet of
Allah and when we engage with Muslims we
get to hear from them quite a lot about
Muhammad and I'm sure those of you who
just open their eyes and check what's
happening on the news you also get to
see how Muslims kill in the name of
Muhammad as well as they want to honor
Muhammad Muhammad's owner is very
important and recently there is a video
circulating on social
media where um Christians or you can say
critic of Islam are making a claim that
Muhammad did not exist I also come
across with a video which was published
approximate uh nine months ago where a
Muslim missionary is expressing um
actually responding a video titled did
Muhammad exist or not once the video has
been pointed out to me I invited Robert
Spencer to come and join me so that he
can respond U what farit is saying um we
kind of have better understanding of
what Muslim thinks regarding how all
this works
out uh how are you doing Robert very
well thank you atun how are you by God's
grace I'm good thank you so I come
across with this video where um farit
respond uh put a video up approximately
a year ago where he's responding J Smith
and aladi regarding um did Muhammad
exist or not um and he makes kind of
quite big claims from his video overall
he expresses we know Muhammad existed
because Islamic tradition tells us so um
I thought we can do with it well you
know J Smith and aladi in their video
they're explaining that it's Islamic
tradition may tell us that Muhammad
existed but it's all very late it's 200
years after he's supposed to have lived
which allows for a great deal of
legendary
elaboration that uh makes for the
stories about Muhammad to be more likely
to be myth than historical fact and so
that's what fared is resp attempting to
respond to and I thank you for bringing
this video to my attention because uh
I've been working on this quite a lot
actually and if you'll pardon me I have
this book Muhammad a critical biography
which is coming out next week that
explores this very question in great
depth okay when we say next week we are
talking about the second week of
September
2024 that's right so if you are going to
watch this in the future please make
sure that is next week I guess it's
going to be disappointed if Muhammad is
not exist because his followers are
simply killing um non-muslims to honor
Muhammad so that will be very
disappointing for his
followers um if that's okay for a lot of
disappointments um if that's okay with
you I'll show um little bit Clips on um
what farit is saying and then you kind
of impact for us what is wrong with what
he's saying yes absolutely okay just
give me a second for me to just pull
down the video Muhammad may not exist
but the video well we're not sure of the
video either no video is exist I
downloaded it all is the problem is I
just need to find it
um I can't remember how I titled it so
that's the
issue the ones you sent me were by the
numbers that I sent you we know nothing
from ibak we know from IB hisam this is
incorrect because we actually have
isak's book that comes through the path
of funus B this is not new information
by the way since the rendition by Unice
was printed in the 1970s unfortunately
both of these experts are oblivious to
it he's talking about IB isak and IB
hisam because J Smith is saying that the
first biographer of Muhammad iban isak
who died in the s60s is which is already
over a hundred years after muhammmad uh
we don't even have his book we only have
it from the fragments of it that were
preserved by iban Hisham early in the
9th century and so uh fared is saying
that no no you you're ignorant J Smith
because we have yunas Ian bukir who
comes earlier and gives us a copy of
what iban isak said but this is not
actually the case he's not uh telling
the truth whether out of ignorance or
malice uh fared is not giving us the
accurate information iban bukir was
indeed one of of the students of iban
isak who is supposed to have taken down
portions of what he taught and so we
have what iban bukir said and he assured
his listeners that he communicated iban
isak's words word for word and so that
sounds very good from fed's point of
view that we have Muhammad's biographer
and we don't have his book but we have
his students book and he took down what
the biographer said word for word Never
mind already that it's over a hundred
years after Muhammad's death leave that
aside for the moment but the problem is
that the medieval literature about
Muhammad tells us that IB bukir took
took the work of iban isak and then
combined it with other
works including other hadiths about
Muhammad and so there is a historian a
contemporary historian rizwi fiser who
wrote in the international Journal of
Middle East studies that iban bukir and
other transmitters of iban isak's work
and I quote did not limit themselves to
passing on what they had received from
their teachers but rather laid claim to
the role of adapting and revising their
material as they saw fit he says they
did this by rearranging abbreviating
expanding and
recasting okay all right um so for me to
understand remember I'm female my brain
doesn't work as well as uh man works so
so while while the claim is earliest
biography of Muhammad we have is from
iak actually we don't have I isak we've
got whatam compiled and edited out um
you are saying um uh even bukara is also
the student of uh I isak um and it is
the same thing like we really don't have
anything before I isak at this well we
don't have anything before IB isak yes
so that's the first problem because iban
isak is 130 years after Muhammad's death
so you have 130 years for people to
embellish the stories to change the
stories to make up new stories to do all
kinds of things with the material then
you have Ian isak but you don't have him
that's J Smith's point that he was
making in the video that fared is
responding to that we only have iban
hasham from 60 years later in the
830s 83 he died in
8:33 so you have him writing presumably
in the 810s 820s and excuse me he's
giving us iban isak but he could have
changed it any number of ways or the
people who got it from changed it in any
number of ways so fared is saying no no
no you're forgetting
that we have this yunas buk and yunas IB
buer gets it straight from iban isak but
the uh early the the early Muslim
historians say that iban bukir took
liberties with ibben isak's work and a
contemporary historian says that he
rearranged abbreviated expanded and
recast what he got from iban isak so IB
bukir is not anymore trustworthy than
anybody else and as a matter of fact we
actually have on record historians
saying he changed what he got from iban
isak which is the whole problem here if
they got straight historical material
and cast passed it on as they got it
then we might be able to trust it but
when they start changing it as
rearranging abbreviating expanding and
recasting as iban bukir did then we
can't trust it okay uh let's say say of
argument uh we don't have anything else
that's all we have even though it has
been changed
uh do we have any book from him or we do
we have his manuscripts because I'm not
aware of his manuscripts or anything
so do you mean is no uh from yeah IB
bukir we have supposedly his work but
also that comes from his students and
here again you have the same problem
it's just something like kicking the can
down the road you still come up with the
question of how much was this changed
from what it originally was okay that
means we don't have his work we've got
his work from his students yes okay good
um
okay um that's clarify quite a lot it's
been like over 130 years after the death
of Muhammad people are trying to put the
biography of Muhammad and you expressed
that there are lots of um addition and
changings has been made to it yes there
are all these different versions of iban
isak's biography so really you can't say
that Ian BK's book or iban hisham's book
or tab's book who also used a lot of
iban isak none of them are really iban
isak because all of them could have been
changed and like almost certainly were
changed actually all you have to do is
compare them to each other as I do in my
new book The this book that compares
them to each other then you see they
can't all be true because they disagree
with one another do I remember correctly
um within 100 years after death of
Muhammad that people were making up
stories about his life and um there was
a guy for example he's been crucified
simply making up stories about life of
Muhammad yeah it's funny because if
with within within 100 years yes if you
go to Islamic tradition you get stories
like this where Muhammad says do not
write down what I say and whoever writes
from me other than the Quran let him
erase it and so then you have all these
stories about Muhammad okay so are they
are they real or are they fake didn't he
tell them not to do it and we have all
these people who transmitted hadiths
supposedly according to the isnad chain
the chain of transmitters but then there
are stories like this asabi says I sat
with IB Umar for a year and I did not
hear him narrate anything from the
messenger of Allah but then if you go to
the Hadith collections you see so many
of them come from IB
Umar it doesn't make any sense either he
he was he was Keeping a Secret from
asabi or maybe none of these really come
from IB Umar okay and so the the thing
is that uh
there seems to have been Traditions
early on that it was wrong to collect
the Traditions about Muhammad's words
and deeds and then later this was
changed and all of this comes from so
much l later after Muhammad is supposed
to have lived that none of it can be
taken at face value yeah and also the
point you are trying to make also you
are pointing out we know from Muslim
sources it is telling us these people
were intentionally changed in what was
it written um there so that kind of
gives also minus Mark to what the people
are trying to do like well that's
another thing of it you know I don't
think sufficient attention is paid to
the fact that the great collectors of
the Hadith rejected so many that bukari
for example According to Islamic
tradition not to islamophobes or some
nonsense like that but According to
Islamic tradition bukari collected
600,000
yeah and he only published 7,000 he
rejected that means he rejected 593
th000 stories of Muhammad as false and
inauthentic yeah where did they come
from the Muslims were fabricating them
plus he did that judgment by himself I
guess we will talk about it when we when
he's talking about bukari part but he
did that judgment by himself not any
revolation at all and he expresses that
um he had a dream therefore through his
dream he was was able to kind of make
that judgment I that like Miracle by
itself but I think I think he was right
the 593 th000 were inauthentic he was
also just wrong about the 7,000 they
were inauthentic
too well he had to write something down
he was
close Okay um let me move to the next
clip um like to add that s isn't the
earliest available to us I actually have
a copy of
um is actually a student of Malik one of
the Servants of the Prophet peace be
upon him okay suan bin dhan this is
another one okay uh this is a forgery as
a matter of fact in Al andalo in the
11th century a s of sulan IB dhan
circulated that it it was supposed to
have been written by him but it was
false there's no record of it from
before the 11th century
and so see he's supposed to have died in
761 so that would be very early that
would be as early as iban isak although
still 130 years after Muhammad but still
from from the standpoint of all the rest
of the material about Muhammad this is
very early so suan IB tadan is supposed
to have written this presumably in in
the early part of the of the 8th Century
but it doesn't appear until the 11th
century in Spain and most Scholars I I
think actually all Scholars agree that
it's a forgery so uh fared is holding it
up and thinking that it's actually an
8th Century work but it's it isn't okay
um just a practical question um farit is
Muslim last time when I checked he was
still Muslim um he just need to repent
but he is Muslim uh and you are not
Muslim and you are telling me the
sources you read tells you um B dark's
work is forgery uh is your s like why
should I trust your sources than um
trusting for it well tell um I don't
think Muslims ever ever lie
never I need that nicely sorry it didn't
come out nicely this is a valid point
because actually just earlier today
since you found this video that uh is
from year ago that we are responding to
now I started to look around and I found
a video that is also from almost a year
ago in which
uh a a supposedly non-muslim scholar
although he's an Islamic apologist uh
what's his name I think it's Joshua
little and he is yeah he's talking about
did Muhammad exist and since I wrote a
book by that title he's talk he talks
about me and he claims to know my motive
although I never met him he's saying oh
he just does this because he hates
Muslims and actually I think you know
Joshua if you if you're seeing this
really you shouldn't make such judgments
about people you that you don't know uh
the whole idea of islamophobia is a
spurious concept designed to inhibit
criticism of Islam and Jihad and so to
say oh this guy he's just islamophobic
and and he hates Muslims and that's why
he's doing this is that's just as as
tendentious and unsupported as to say
well fared must be telling the truth
because he's a Muslim when Islam
actually allows for being dishonest to
unbelievers in order to uh win them over
or make them complacent about Jihad
violence or Sharia or whatever and so if
if fared comes from a tradition that
allows for dishonesty why should we
trust him about this whereas when you
have historians who were not Muslim like
me and like R source for suan IB Tarkan
is Robert Kerr uh who is one of the
inara group that is looking into the
origins of early Islam neither he nor I
have any interest in showing one way or
the other whether Muhammad existed or
not obviously I've written two books
about this at this point I'm very
interested in the topic but I didn't go
in thinking to the research thinking I
was is going to come to this conclusion
or that conclusion the fact that I write
about Jihad and I'm against it everybody
should be against it it's it's inhumane
Sharia is inhumane these things don't
mean that you hate Muslims to talk about
them but the thing is that it doesn't
make any difference to my work about
Islamic Jihad to say whether Muhammad
existed or not because whether he
existed or not Muslims are quoting him
in order to jus ify violence and
supremacism and hatred and so that's a
separate question as
to what we should do about Muslims who
believe in Muhammad and so on and it's a
very complex question that is worth
discussing but the fact is that I could
have continued in that work and never
explored this issue or written that
Muhammad was actually historically
accurate if that was what the evidence
led to but I was led by the evidence
Robert Kerr was led by the evidence and
so when we see that it leads against
Muhammad then we say that if it had led
toward Muhammad being a historical
figure that's all the same to me I know
um Muslims for example who look at the
same evidence same fundings um and they
confirm yes um this this is this this is
this but when they want to come to their
conclusion they are very biased on their
conclusion I have no problem with that
because I know Islam forces them to do
so but evidence is there people for
people to check it out I someone who
kind of I know it is wrong but I am
someone who when I listen this Muslim
missionaries who is been in the world of
apologetic for a while and then they
simply hold the book and pretend they
don't know this book is being forged I
just find that dishonest uh but that's
me that's me Pro he's being very honest
oh yeah he's as honest as the days long
for Reed yes okay if that's okay with
you I'll turn to the third clip yep
mamad that is the Hadith the first to
write them down in a categorized form to
compile him is Al buhari look at his
dates 870 right um that's absolutely
incorrect we actually have multiple
works that predate bukari we have for
example which predates bukari I got a
copy of mus
Abu right here um I got a copy of musnad
Ahmed right here um I got a copy of M
Malik right here um all these books weed
bukari by quite a bit okay here we go
again same thing see he's he given you
these names now and it sounds impressive
to somebody who has not studied in the
field and they hear okay we've got
before bukari we've got abiba we've got
musnad Abu da we've got musnad Ahmed we
got muat Malik and so on and so it all
sounds very like very much like Jay is
not being uh honest or is not well
informed and is simply ignorant of
Hadith collections that predate bukari
but when we talk about predating bukari
here again fared is being misleading as
Jay noted bukari died in 870 so abuba
that uh is the first one that that fared
picks up he died in
849 he was born in
775 Muhammad is supposed to have died in
632 so abish Sheba is hardly any more
any closer to the actual historical
events if there were any than bukari is
and it's likely that their careers
overlapped to a tremendous degree and
that they were both out collecting
Hadith around the same time
because uh abish Sheba only died what is
it 49 21 years before bukari so uh
that's not a significant difference uh
so if I remember correctly I need to
check but um he's supposed to have
approximately 37,000 hadit collected oh
yeah
37,000 and none of them are made into
the our our decades now I and that
didn't even made into the canonization
of the hadiths I find that very much
stressed um yes that's another very
important thing that all these early
collections that uh or supposedly early
collections that fared is invoking none
of them are sah
reliable that is the classified by
Islamic scholars as being reliable they
might be early but they're not they're
not considered as reliable as bukari and
Muslim and the other sah the six uh
reliable collections so Farid of course
doesn't mention that he wants to give
the impression that they have very early
Hadith collections that are reliable not
even the Islamic scholars say that yeah
as I expressed earlier like within 100
years of death of Muhammad Muslims were
crucified simply forging the customs of
Muhammad forging the hadit yes so we
first he talked about Abu shba which we
responded now and then also I think um
he talks about Abu um T yes the the
musnad Abu da that's the work of Abu
daisi and I if you have the screenshot
for that the screenshot let me put it on
the screen yeah this is from the Islamic
bookstore online you can find this
online seatu SWA uh because don't have a
copy of uh musnad Abid daud I thought
I'd go get one since fared mentioned it
so I went shopping and uh I saw that it
says here in this uh ad for the book at
this Bookshop here is the musnad of Abu
daisi who's supposed to have died in 204
after the Hijra so in other words around
800 ad and uh it says he gathers 2,890
hadiths the musnad are collections which
are classif by narrators and therefore
by sahabas imisi Begins for example by
the 10 companions promised to Paradise
it seems that the collection is not
directly the work of the
Imam but what his pupil yunus IB Habib
assembled from what the shik transmitted
to him and this is see I wanted to put
this up because this is the Islamic
bookstore that is selling mus AB it's
telling you it's not from his time it's
from the time of his pupil it's later so
so they are selling this for
$28 yes and in their description they
are saying well if you are going to buy
this please remember this is not his
book this is from what his student
gather together that's right attribute
to him and uh for it was simply at this
occasion I think I can say intentionally
misguiding people regarding is to be one
of the earliest sources and it expresses
that um it has approximate
2,890 hadits and they didn't make um to
Islamic um coronation of the hadits yeah
it does seem so that fared must know
this because he held the book up he said
he had it so if he's opened it if he's
read it then he must have come to the
place where it says this is not the work
of the shik this is the work of his
pupil Unice inhib and yet he didn't
bother to tell us that well in that case
I think I have to take my statement back
as he's done this intentionally because
some people buy the books and they like
the color of it and they never read it
maybe he's in one of this is one of that
book is just collecting them well it is
a nice
color um okay so um we talked about um
ABI shba we talked about AB Abu alal
and um who else was um then the next one
he says is musnad Ahmed which is the
work of akmed IB hanbal the great
Islamic jurist who died in
855 now remember he's talking about
hadiths before bukari and P putting
these names out there as if these are
the names of very
early very early collectors of the
Hadith where ammed IB hanbal died in 855
and bukari in 8 70 well so well well
well just a second you have no idea what
people can achieve within 20 years yes
that's true so probably he's just
thinking well in 20 years bukar before
bukari people had this awesome mindset
and they were able to put everything
together yes and yet musar akmad as you
noted it's still not one of the
canonical Hadith collections one of the
ones that are considered sah reliable uh
uh and so we we we still have to go back
to bukari and then Muslim after him for
the ones that are actually certified as
being reliable in Islamic tradition not
by
islamophobes yeah and it's very
difficult to use um uh use that with
Muslims um sometimes I use some of the
stories um to engage with Muslims they
simply just like put under the bush uh
they don't want to do anything with it
they don't trust it they don't believe
it but uh we were told by farit that
apparently it is since it is before
bukari it must be trustworthy or
something yes and then there's he the
last one he mentions in that group is
Maat Malik the Imam Malik died in 795
and so that is marginally earlier but
here again we have the Judgment of
Islamic scholars Islamic tradition which
he never mentions that M Malik as early
as it is is not considered to be one of
the most reli ible Hadith Collections
and the ones that come later are and so
even if you grant that muat Malik is
early therefore it must be giving us the
real information about Muhammad he M
Malik the Imam Malik died in
795 and so that's already 100 over 150
years after Muhammad is supposed to have
died it's still far too long a gap for
us to be talking about historical
reliability and contains only
1,823 stories yeah that's that's poultry
compared to bukari yeah and you are
expressing well since they are bit too
late and um not identified as there is a
question on trustworthy of um this book
as well yes uh did he mention anyone
else yes the in the next clip I believe
it is okay let me pull the next clip Up
of these books
is which was written um within 50 years
from the death of the Prophet peace be
upon him ham is also a student of a
companion of the Prophet peace be upon
him now I really I really am thinking
that you're right he's just not being
honest because uh I know I know it's
hard to believe fared not being honest I
know how could this be uh but fared says
that sah H comes from 50 years after the
death of Muhammad was written within 50
years after the death of Muhammad that
would put it at 682 would it not at the
latest yeah it must have been sah sahat
ham must have been written by 682 for
fared to be telling the truth all right
but who wrote it ham
IB and when was he born
7199 no no no I know this one
yeah in Islam god god of Islam is so
capable remember like Muhammad's mother
was like pregnant for four years um in
this occasion probably he was writing
the customs of Muhammad before he even
end up in the tummy of his mommy amazing
amazing sorry just
alhamdulillah yes so you see I don't
think I I I love fed I love you but I
don't think you're being honest here uh
come on how could he write a book in 682
if he was born in
79 also here again as we have seen all
through this broadcast hamam iab's work
is lost we do not have it just like iban
isak just like IB bukir just like all
the other ones we have copies that come
from his students that could have been
revised
extensively and so so we cannot take it
as being an early work at
all and anyway what why did you try to
fool your your your viewers into
thinking this was an early book within
50 years of Muhammad's life I'm talking
to you fared why did you die why did you
try to fool people into thinking that
when you knew that hamam wasn't born yet
I am not the lawyer for farit but I know
without lies Islam dies there you go
people stuck in Islam because they are
forced to believe in this lies and they
cannot question it so when someone who
has the platform takes the books and
then simply lies probably the book they
never even bother to read it then Their
audience believe those kind of things
and that keeps them in Islam that means
they will end up in hell for long long
long long long time well it does remind
me of a statement of Jesus himself
saying that uh you are of your father
the devil and you you lie consequently
as a result of being the children of the
Father of
Lies well they should think about what
uh when they have to lie to defend their
God maybe their God isn't worth
defending well that might be the case
without lies Islam dies um okay
uh shall I move to the next clip yes
okay get ready four more lies about
books of and we have
classical that predate by quite a while
like I got here a copy of which predates
by over 150 years this was because Jay
was saying that the T the commentaries
on the Quran are also likewise late that
they we don't have for example why
wouldn't we have if they had the Quran
by
653 whenman is supposed to have codified
it and collected it and burnt the
variants and distributed it everywhere
why don't we have a toughest tough sear
from right then from the60s or 70s but
we don't we don't have anything until
once again the 9th century and so he's
saying no no no we have the T jur which
is 150 years before
Tu and so this also is misleading at
best tan J likewise as is a refrain
through this broadcast it is not his own
work but is preserved in the lecture
notes of his students and who tells us
that Ahmad IB
hanbal akmad IB hanbal who is the
Islamic jurist and Hadith collector that
fared invoked earlier he tells us that
we don't have the work of of the tapir
of IB
juraj that it's his students who whose
notes we
have and he doesn't fared doesn't bother
to tell us that is the date correct
regard the date he gives is that date
correct 150 years before before Tu yes
but we don't have anything from
that but still give credit this time
like he didn't lie about the date no
yeah roughly it's correct but there's
nothing there noal says his students put
it together okay says IB J's students
put it together okay got it
okay okay um anything else was in that
side I think that's it and then there's
one last statement from fared here okay
let's go to that one be upon Him is more
authentic than major doctrinal
attributions to Jesus from our
historical reports we can prove that
Muhammad peace be upon Him ate chicken
while you cannot even prove that Jesus
peace be upon Him claimed to be
God this is important this is very
important it's very important what he's
saying is that we have such detailed
biographical information about Muhammad
we know what he ate we we know he ate
chicken not only chicken we know he beat
his wife you know he murdered genocide
he committed genocide we know he called
woman animals we know lots of things
about traditional account yes yeah we
know a great deal and me then he saying
we know more you can't even prove as
Christians that Jesus said he was God
well obviously we can because in John
8:58 Jesus says before Abraham was I am
which is the name of God according to
the Book of Exodus and the appearance of
God to Moses so Jesus is saying that he
is the god who appeared to Moses this is
pretty clear uh of course fared would
say no no no that book is corrupt how do
we know that book is corrupt because the
Islam says so but the Quran says that
the uh Christians will never be rightly
guided until they obey what's in the
gospel and so he's SC fed has a big
problem with this that the Quran directs
Christians to follow the gospel the
gospel says that Jesus said he was
divine and now he's claiming that
there's no way for Christians to prove
that Jesus said he was divine this
indicates that fared himself does not
believe in the Quran and is a mad and uh
thus in deep trouble with his fellow
Muslim or could be soon uh but also more
importantly and Al in all seriousness
he's claiming that the historical
records of Muhammad are more his more
reliable than the historical records
about Jesus this is flatly false and
it's very important to know because a
lot of people say this and they think
that this is true but you can make a a
very clear comparison because Muhammad
is supposed to have died died in the
630s and Jesus is supposed to have died
in the 30s in the first century of the
Christian era or CE or ad you know all
the the the years that we count from
today and so you have from the 30s to
the 90s you have in Christianity the uh
writing of the New Testament the writing
of the post-apostolic writings the
post-apostolic fathers who were the
disciples of the Apostles like Clement
of Rome and Ignatius of Antioch and
Ignatius of Antioch is actually about 10
years after that but uh you have very
early writings of of post post-apostolic
writings of the Christians you have
churches all over the Mediterranean
world and you have several incidents of
non-christians like flavius Josephus and
tacitus writing about the
Christians and knowing that they exist
now take the 630s to the 690s the exact
same period of time time 600 years later
and you don't you have the Arabs
Conquering the Middle East and North
Africa and Persia and parts of India
with tremendous speed and
power but in all that extraordinary
growth and with many records of the
non-muslims writing about being
conquered and about the conquerors you
don't have any mention of the Quran or
Islam
or Allah or Muhammad except for a few
scattered mentions that do not
correspond to what we know today or
think we know about the prophet of Islam
and so for fared to say that Islam has a
solid historical foundation and
Christianity does not is exactly the
opposite of what is true Christianity
has a much stronger historical
Foundation than Islam it's just that
Islams has been covered over by so many
lies and distortions and half truths and
westerners in particular don't know the
beginnings of Islam so they tend to take
the story at face value that's the
difference but when you look at it you
see there's a remarkable elaboration of
Christianity in the first 60 years of
Christianity that is readily
documentable versus 60 years of Conquest
in which the you would expect the
conquerors to be saying yes we are
conquering you because Muhammad our
prophet told us that we should go out
and fight until religion is all for
Allah and that's in our holy book the
Quran and so on and our new religion
Islam and and there's no mention of it
none sophronius of Jerusalem the
patriarch of Jerusalem in the 630s when
the Arabs
conquered there's a story that the Calef
Umar came and met him and saphronia was
taking him around the city and when they
got to the Church of the Holy Seiler
which is built over the tomb where Jesus
was buried and where he rose from the
dead sophronius invited him to go and
pray inside and Umar said no no I won't
go pray inside because then my followers
will claim this for a church and I want
to leave it for you Christian claim it
for a mosque excuse me and I want to
leave it for you Christians and so this
is supposed to be a story about how Umar
was magnanimous and Islam is tolerant
but that also is a ninth Century story
we have lots of writings of ronus many
many writings of sophronius were
preserved and he never mentions Umar he
never mentions Muhammad he never
mentions Muslims he calls them hagaren
or sarasin he never mentions Islam he
never mentions the Quran he doesn't show
any clue that those things existed all
he knows is that the Arabs came and
conquered and they're burning the
churches and he sees it as the
punishment of God for the sins of the
Christians in Jerusalem but he does and
he talks a great deal about that and
about the conquerors but he gives no
hint that they are people with a new
religion a new holy book and a new
Prophet now you are telling me you've
got approximate 200 over 200 years Gap
within the history of
Islam where everyone else is silent
about Muslims everyone is silent about
Muhammad everyone is silent about Islam
uh yet like within couple of centuries
Islam conquer Islam reached aeran to
Spain um to North Africa yet Arabs the
Arabs conqu Muslims didn't conquer no no
from Islamic Traditions so they kind of
spread all the way and no one kind of
talking about that even like in the
story of um uh Hebrews when they go to
the Canaanites there are um artifacts
talks about like oh people are coming
and then attacking us all that and
that's a think about it that taking
place around 1,400 BC and people are
talking about it versus something is
happening around 600 ads or 700 ads and
no one is talking about it I find that
like concerning well it's extraordinary
because the Arabs are conquering half of
the known world and identifying them as
this is Islam this is nobody says
Muslims nobody says Islam there's a
historian Robert holand and he's also
very dishonest he collects the early
mentions about the about Islam Islam I
think his book is called Islam as others
saw it or something like that uh I can't
remember the name of it but it's a very
misleading book because he collects
early literature that mentioned the Arab
conquerors and he said when they say the
taay came came or the sarens came or the
hagarenes came he says he translates it
the Muslims came but they didn't say
Muslims nobody said Muslims nobody had
any clue there was such a thing as Islam
there's no mention of it in all this
time and so he's actively misleading
people into thinking there was early
mention of Islam when there was not
maybe his friend with fit oh I bet so or
or or people like him yeah so now what
we is we just went through a couple of
statements which is made by farit
regarding um how he knows that Muhammad
is existed and then we went through to
show actually he's not being very honest
and uh Islamic kind of those
informations regarding yes maybe Muslims
figured out today Muhammad like chicken
and then eat chicken after murdering
chicken all that and Muslims figured
that y Muhammad beat his wife therefore
let us to do it as well but at the end
those in formations come to us from the
historical perspective pretty pretty
late yes exactly on conclusion well the
it's a it's because he uh uh is
comparing this to Christianity it's
important to note that most historians
agree that the New Testament was
completed by the F end of the first
century and some of them earlier say
that's earlier than that uh whereas you
don't have Quran being quoted in the
early the the the first 60 years of
Islam you don't have anybody even giving
any idea that it
exists even on that topic like there is
a huge like I think it's misguiding to
even compare them because in first
century we were using Papyrus so we were
not rich people who would just like
murder animal and then use the skin to
write it versus in seventh century
Muslims were rich and is uh like
According to Islamic tradition it has
been all controlled by the khif yet they
were not able to put things together uh
that's a concerning as well like it's I
think it's not fair to compare them
because life conditions were very
different in first century versus in
seventh century even though they had uh
in today's standards let's say they had
Oxford University but they choose to not
use it or choose to ignore it well if
the condition were different and they
certainly were then that should be
favorable to Islam then we should think
that there would be more dissemination
of Islam in the seventh century than of
Christianity in the first and yet there
isn't well um I'm grateful that you have
been available to um come and then do
rebuttle for this video really
appreciate that um have you got last
words um on the video don't believe
fared okay B so so we follow the basic
principles if the lips of Muslims are
moving don't take them seriously prob
they are lying they mising um anyway um
really appreciate taking time and then
helping us to think through and look at
from the historical perspective I am
sure people have now more questions to
ask Muslims and then I move forward from
this um once again thank you very much
for joining me God bless you thank you